People are going to have to start
paying their fair share in taxes.
Their “fair share?”
Are you paying your fair share?
What would that be?
Do you have a specific on the tax rate?
You know, you look at our tax rates back in the ‘60s
STOSSEL: On 60 minutes,
the darling of the progressive movement,
didn’t appear to have a specific rate in mind
but then she said…
Ocasio-Cortez: Sometimes you see tax rates
as high as 60 or 70%.
STOSSEL: Suddenly that became the progressive plan.
I can support folks at the top paying their fair share.
70 percent, 80 percent, we’ve had it as high as 90 percent
STOSSEL: 90% was the top tax rate when I was a kid
and now democrats say,
“if we just raise rates on the wealthy,
government will have plenty of money
to pay for all their wonderful programs.”
[sound of money counting]
But it’s a myth.
What progressives don’t say is that:
No one actually paid anywhere close to those rates.
No one?
No one.
Economic historian Phillip Magness says
it’s not surprising that progressives don’t know that
90% tax rates didn’t bring in lots of money.
You know, who has the time and the interest
to sit around and dig through that line by line?
You.
Me. I'm apparently the guy.
He's researched old tax codes for over a decade.
You must be a really boring guy.
I can be.
[Sound of plane engine ]
During World War II, America’s 90% tax bracket
didn’t bring in that much more money
because rich people found loopholes.
And then, because the high rates discouraged work
President Kennedy backed a bill that
lowered the top rate to 70%.
President Kennedy: The billions of dollars
this bill would place in the hands of the consumer
and our businessmen
will have both immediate and permanent benefits
to our economy.
[applause]
STOSSEL: But it turned out that the 70% rate
wasn’t very real either.
No one paid 70%, let alone 90%?
Right.
What did they pay?
A millionaire on average would pay 41%
Because when taxes are high, rich people find loopholes.
There’s all these deductions and exemptions
and carve outs that are intentionally baked
into the tax code.
Newspapers ran ads:
"Cruise for free!"
$2499 value.
Basically take a vacation around the Caribbean,
but while you're onboard the ship you attend say,
an investing seminar or a real estate seminar
then write off the trip.
The whole trip?
The whole trip.
Deductions became so complex
that rich people,
instead of inventing, say a precursor to the iPhone,
hired accountants to study the tax code.
Who can afford the best accountants?
It's always the wealthy.
STOSSEL: Today the top tax rate is 37%.
The top rate started dropping again after
Ronald Reagan said 70% was outrageous:
President Reagan: Our tax system
could only be described as un-American.
And the democrats actually agree with him.
Reagan goes to the table and says, "Let's make a deal."
We can cut the rates down to something
closer in approximation to what we have today
and in exchange we'll consolidate the tax code.
Vacation deductions and other exemptions were killed,
leading to a slightly simpler tax code
and surprise, the lower rates brought in
just as much money.
Turns out that tax revenue as a
percentage of the economy
stays about the same
no matter what the top tax rate is.
When rates are high, rich people sometimes work less.
It’s just economics.
People don’t work to pay taxes.
Economist Art Laffer told president Reagan
rich people will evade high taxes.
They’ll change where they earn their income.
They’ll change how they earn their income.
They’ll change how much they earn,
when they receive the income.
They’ll change all of those things to minimize taxes.
They will leave the United States.
And this not-yet-president pointed out that
if taxes go up, rich people may move away.
You haven’t left.
I haven’t left yet.
Are you going to leave?
Big story if I leave, I guess.
If I leave New York that’s a big story.
Look, the rich people are going to leave.
And other people are going to leave.
You're going to end up with lots of people
that don’t produce.
And then,
that’s the spiral that’s the end.
That's what's happened and
there's some European examples.
So France attempted a massive tax
on its wealthiest earners.
What they found is the business people
left in a mass exodus from the country.
But progressives are selective when they look at history
Under republican president, republican administration,
Dwight Eisenhower we had 90% marginal tax rates.
The government will collect more and do good things.
Well, that's the claim.
But you're asking for an economic disaster.
So I ask the question,
do we leave it in the private sector
where the market decides?
Or do we subject it to corrupt politicians?
I say, let the market decide.
Of course, when the market decides,
some people get really rich.
STOSSEL: And then progressives say:
Sen. Sanders: The rich get richer and the poor get poorer.
But it’s not true.
The poor don’t get poorer.
That’s another economic myth.
We will cover that, in an upcoming video.